hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba hi
I'm John Humphrey we are doing a topper
war tear video request from our good
friend screenwriter Jason Nolan who I'm
hoping will come on the channel sometime
soon this is from the channel blimeycow
they have five hundred thirty nine
thousand followers good for them and
this video is titled Avengers end game
was the first MCU film he saw no way
what's it about well let's find out
let's find out
thanks to audible for sponsoring this
video go to audible.com slash cow or
text the word cow to five hundred five
hundred to get a free audiobook today
incredibly audible Adams worried that no
one's gonna believe this
no one's gonna believe me they're gonna
think I'm making this out like this is
real I I don't know how I don't know
this is my brother Jordan he's never
seen a Marvel Cinematic Universe movie
not one honestly if I'm being honest I
don't really know who is in this movie I
know there's like Captain America so I
had an idea what would happen if I took
him to see endgame with follow the story
at all would any of you tell me if you
know anything about any of these movies
how many over there like how long has
this been going on for 11 years
yes it's 2008 Iron Man do I know
anything about have I seen it but in the
original Iron Man lie said honestly
maybe I've seen a third of it and I fell
asleep that's the only one I don't
remember
I add what I don't think equals a hammer
yeah that's pretty much all I know there
you go Captain America the First Avenger
was that one or two movies that's one
movie babe like the little one just the
Avengers I didn't realize they had the
individual then they started making the
Avengers yeah okay I saw that night I
heard about I actually heard about that
one but I've never seen oh no I've never
heard of that
how many people like what that yeah they
made in the MCU
this one exists that's I was excited to
see that one there's so much hype around
that I was like I don't know now I feel
like I'm making some kind of political
statement if i watch it one way or the
other that's this one that was part one
oh no I know when are we getting to
parts you like they are these in order
yes you know that from our previous
videos that
talk about the main bad guy you remember
what his name is we talking about I mean
that guy he knows yes and do you
remember what things did her be telling
you when he turned somebody to dust yes
but how many people was it like one of
the best one of the good guys several
good guys I expect that it should be one
of the most confusing experiences but I
I think that it will actually probably
be good if this many people are seeing
it right even you can expect here we go
Oh God while we wait for Jordan to watch
end game I just wanted to say that I'm
so grateful my brother finally listened
to me and agreed to watch an MCU movie
you know listening makes us smarter more
connected people there's no better way
to start listening now get more than
ever before you get to choose three
titles each month one audiobook plus two
audible originals that you can't hear
anywhere else they also have some great
Marvel audiobooks Dylan - including
infinity Wars destiny arrives
Thanos Titan consumed Black Widow
forever red and a whole lot more they
offer free and easy audio book exchanges
credits you can normally image library
you can keep even if you cancel you can
start listening with a 30-day audible
trial and your first audiobook plus -
audible originals are free so go to
audible.com slash cow or text cow 500
500 again that's a free audiobook and a
couple of audible originals when you go
to audible.com slash cow or text cow at
a 500 500 Wow did I talk about that for
three hours well let's see what my
brother
I really liked it a lot but the the I
think it was store they really say his
name I don't think but that was like
reviews really funny I didn't obviously
understand most of the characters like
backstories and stuff that they were
like talking about certain things like
especially at the end of the movie went
like all of these characters came out
dislike portals and no okay I think my
biggest question in this whole thing
people like the blue they could do
diddly-squat and then all of a sudden
like the Black Panther and all of his
order people and then like all these
other if you would works on in the
Avengers to like why didn't I just help
them the whole movie was about saving
those people best joke at the end those
were the big reappearing I just thought
because I didn't even know who turned to
dust before I was like maybe it was like
a couple of key people but then when the
beginning of the movie started which was
like that scene of that dad and the girl
would do in the bow and arrow I thought
that that was like a preview for another
movie
[Laughter]
yeah yeah I remember growing up okay
that's why I was like this so no big
death there were few other so little to
me I
so when they were on that clip when she
jumped off the cliff yeah I didn't know
her name
nobody was confusing you know that's
like they just assumed you knew all
these people's names
she was a soul for a soul you know yeah
I realized I thought that all the sudden
they realized that what's that one guy
the one guy who was really emotionally
distressed like half that movie trying
to get her off the I thought we realized
all at once that he was a bad guy right
then because I was like he's trying I
didn't know what was happening like he's
trying to throw her off this this thing
cuz even one but never like he was
trying to stop yeah they were both kind
of stuff the other one yeah I started to
realize that once he was trying to save
her I was distraught right I was trying
to save her yeah it was very long no
I'll tell you when I said when I when I
started to realize I was really dying to
get out of there it was when Captain
America was going back in time to return
for some reason all alone all by himself
all those stupid stones that you need to
get back they may it look so easy they
again they walk in chop his head off and
then it was like wow this guy is such a
wimp you know I think this big deal I
think the idea was that now they had
Captain Marvel on their side it was when
that tree guy there like all the kids
that liked animals yes when he came
walking through the portal I was like I
thought I didn't know that he was a
friend
yeah I like people must have shown that
is this too long when people don't think
this is funny this just seemed keeps
going like everybody in the theater was
not so that was good
I think if it wasn't for those two guys
I really would not like this movie I was
looking for anything to grasp onto and
those really went through or showed up
kind of like I think probably they make
Thor into the Hulk that way for people
like you who just walk into the movie
[Music]
did you think about the I thought I was
sheltered and I saw this guy and here's
what one of these movies is I just don't
care
like my parents are like
so I was happy you know it made me happy
when I bought when I watched this movie
and it was like actually you know good
was decent
in my opinion I would have this is like
probably New Orleans first of all time
it would make me very sad if I walked
away from this was like this was
terrible this is a great loss this it
would have made me there's a little I
like there would be some disconnect
between me and everybody else why like
why don't I think this story or
something but I didn't know if I man
when they were like hey you need to come
and like help us make this Time Machine
bottom lines like hey I have a family
now I didn't get infected by the dust or
whatever and then all of a sudden he
goes back in time it was I talked about
how laughs we'll listen to make a time
machine and he goes in and like talks to
Siri for like two seconds oh great yeah
lovely little chronic we've never seen
this guy's videos before blimeycow but I
really like this obviously this is not
his main content that just wouldn't make
sense just introduce my brother to stuff
all the time
it's my channel for curious to know what
the rest of his content would be like
but I really like its editing style like
it's not too hyper fancy other the lace
in this video right here it's not you
know too too stylish was very much like
a doc you've log yeah but it's really
well done really well timed as well it
got really great really great weight
quality he's great got great quality to
it and I thought his brother was
hilarious Doctor Strange
is that a joke I've thought about that
what would anyone actually watch this
movie if they haven't seen most of the
Marvel movies and what kind of took me
for a surprise is how headon I feel like
you would have at least heard some stuff
well how he was like is how I am with
sports where people know things really
you don't know about them like I don't
know what you're talking about
oh yeah none of that information ever
enters my brain so it was pretty
fascinating to see how something's in
such big pop culture which is everywhere
on the internet I'm like that must not
reach his algorithm as I've met people
who haven't watched this movie because
they're like I haven't seen them all and
I just feel like I'd be confused so I
can't imagine his experience but him
recounting the experience was so damn
funny just from that perspective of not
knowing you know I love the he took
moments to be like I figured you know
people who know would probably care
about this thing with Ironman or this
thing with Captain America I didn't care
and it's funny because I think it was
really telling the way they touched on
that point about how like yeah perhaps
in an effort to reach out to people like
you and also to keep people who don't
have as much experience entertained they
you know did punch up Thor's comedy
factor and they did you know make Hulk a
very appealing character and stuff like
that yeah I mean I don't think that's
why they did it but it's a fascinating
thought it's gonna reminds you of like
Anton Yelchin yeah it meets Charlie he's
kind of like a little combination of all
that right there it's one of those
things where he's making funnest I we've
seen it from just doing this channel
that if we're being introduced to some
kind of fandom and if we happen to crack
a joke or two it's like oh that doesn't
fly over well the comment boxes you know
not always no yeah I've never seen BTS
before Here I am making jokes are they
setting right now it's cool to see this
really outside observant perspective on
the matter and wondering like how will
this film communicate to people like
that
I've been fastened to see a film series
of this guy where he keeps watching them
backwards like he
it's on - Captain Marvel back you know
see how it all works in Reverse and see
if the same things that frustrated
people the one wave frustrate him in
Reverse and and if he loves the same
highs and lows yeah yeah or even seem
like his reaction that things about you
know spider-man that's all that one
right he's the handicar fruit won't hurt
I'm learning this information so late in
the game yeah or being witness to people
who are this person behind us was
balling devastated during this which hey
I mean that happened during our
screenings - another thing about his
editing as well I love the way he
inserted the audibles mastership - you
know like how much fun he's had with it
we do sponsorships from time to time and
I've been looking for a ways to like get
inspired to do some more funny ways of
inserting in and I really love the way
you handled it here that was great man
listen more of his channel with like his
description here let's go to his about
new video every Monday great so it's a
video channel I mean his most popular
video 10 things you should never say to
a guy 10 things you should never say to
a girl Nessie Mondays interesting so
he's got sort of like a vlog topic
channel okay slice rival life social
instincts yeah man how not to creep out
girls this is my kind of channel right
here using girl I would watch this
channel for sure ten ways to get the
right guy to like you where how do you
get the wrong guy I thought it might be
like fandom related content a lot of it
just seems about like social things yeah
yes like they only dip into fandom
perhaps for you know once in a while
when it's like something everyone will
be talking says like him and his brother
do it and I could actually kind of see
that just from watching this video
because there's sort of this energy
that's being communicated of just being
honest if being authentic yeah one that
was for me enhanced by the fact that you
have like a group of people off screen
who are all shouting out random detail
yeah I'm kind of trying to yeah guide
along this chat this like before hands
sort of determining of how much he's
aware of going in if it's funny
experiencing that of like we know these
things and how he has her pretty and
them made for some hilarious content
that was great yeah that was great
and as a driving to these guys
yeah that's great great yeah answered
the question we're all really cool I
think the brother did a really good job
at doing was making fun of how he viewed
some people reacting but not making fun
of the people yeah he's actually a
really good communicator you think about
cuz he's like the whole thing with the
Thor hammer yeah when he got everyone's
like whoa no idea why people were
freaking out yeah yeah they paint that
really funny without insulting the
people who really were dazzled by that
moment you know yeah one that's probably
a smart thing because if he was too
mean-spirited you know people might come
and burn him on a stake did you order
original recipe or extra crispy probably
cut my curly hair like him too dude you
should exactly model your life I think I
want to be him I think you should forget
everything you know about the Marvel
Cinematic in
yeah dude let's just combine in a very
disproportionate way find some elements
of us it would be this guy yeah well
thanks Jason for requesting this man
Jason where you gonna come out here I
thought you were out here last month
apparently and I are till like closer to
the end of May you got to come on this
channel seriously you guys will love
Jason Dolan you're gonna love him he's
great at kissing ass all day long mm-hmm
he's got I would drop in names drop a
name if you want to work with any
producers who watch this channel if
you're looking for a screenwriter who
will brown-nose you the entire time it's
the Dolan Jason we'll always yes and you
no matter what you guys asked for he's
what you would call a future major
sellout oh hell yeah and that's the kind
of guy who often to this channel yeah
man ain't that right Jason
Oh invite them to your next mixer thanks
for being one of our top award to your
pledges buddy
and also thanks for the camera that
we're shooting on and someday we'll get
that shirt to you you just keep on
sucking dick keep on us in that day all
right well guys make sure to subscribe
to this channel blimeycow you can
subscribe to the reject nation give this
video like if you like to
you guys later